let the record state that I've got my
hands covered my crotch to avoid this
being a cross shot I'm just gonna put my
brunch directly in front of the lens hi
reject nation I'm Greg Alva John
Humphrey achar Kirk I'm Jabby Kawai
these two from the get Jabby channel are
joining us today for a reaction to the
trailer for a glass M night Shyamalan a
Dada da days movie the crossover of
unbreakable and split are you guys
excited I'm really excited I'm very
excited what's unbreakable
I too am excited I'm breakable it's a
Michael Jackson album his last one
actually really quick patron the day
shout out for Mikael Lyndon this child's
gonna be a little different because I
need to apologize I was talking with
this guy for a while
and I kept referring to Sweden as
Switzerland and it really upset him it
really triggered a bad part of his
memory I don't know maybe some type of
psychological abuse or whatever it
seemed like his personality really sweat
in the moment ah see how I link that the
same countries they just had different
names like you next would go in
California you just change yourself a
lot of fans yeah anyway let's watch this
trailer people Sarah Paulson hi that's
amazing to meet you it is simply
extraordinary
maybe this one makes sense if I explain
Who I am my name is dr. le staple
psychiatrist my work concerns in
particular time of delusion of grandeur
[Music]
I specialize in those individuals who
believe they are super convinced you
have extraordinary gifts like something
out of a comic book interesting they're
all crazy David Dunn the only person to
survive that dream right all those years
ago I'm in security do you think you
have question is your belief that you
are something more than human and yet it
is true but you have an extraordinary
thank you
this is not a cartoon this is the real
world no way and yet some of us still
don't die with bullets all of us can
still bend steel
I've been waiting for Moodle to see that
we exist
with this trio set relax here the Sun is
not prepared streaming our doctors
[Music]
what do you call you sir firstly mr.
lastname what back Jinyu I'm really
excited by this I'm glad that they're
doing a sequel I'll follow up I mean I
know it was always planned but it's
great that we get to spend more time
with the character from split because
they didn't explore all of his
personalities in his installment and
that really frustrated me so being able
to see more of his personalities here is
really cool unbreakable and split or two
very totally different movies and even
though it's a pretty fast-paced trailer
I feel like gathering the tone from
Sarah Paulsen's opening moment can kind
of give you a better ideas like I feel
like m9 might have found the right blend
of tones to combine both unbreakable and
split that one moment that really got me
chills was when David Dunn walks bumps
into James McAvoy then he gets the
flashes of him like oh my god the phone
never wait or right there nobody here
now the main plots really interesting to
me is I feels like they're primarily
gonna be interacting inside of this like
psych asylum or something like that yes
how he keeps a low budget but the thing
that caught my attention was when they
were actually going head-to-head
fighting I thought that's what you're
going to talk about because it's
exciting to see like the unbreakable guy
go against this monster feast I mean
that's pretty cool is his most
formidable enemy yeah I mean this really
got me excited in the way that like a
lot of other crossovers have it and it's
funny because this isn't even
technically a crossover it's all the
same universe and yet it felt like that
kind of event it got me that sort of
excited to see the three of these guys
finally in a room together and it looks
like this movies really gonna use that
to it yeah you look new but also
reminiscent and it just got me super
excited I like the idea of them being in
the asylum because you get to have a lot
of them interacting with each other
throughout the whole film with Samuel
Jackson being the center between these
two I also really like that they brought
back the girl from yeah yeah there
aren't too many superhero films where
it's just a lot of dialogue heavy stuff
and then talking about their powers and
what yeah that's gonna be an interesting
aspect of this well I like them going
with that angle of you know people who
have the delusion that they are
superheroes
yeah study you and and what's gonna come
out of that to Sarah Paulsen's a
terrific actress I'm excited to see them
utilize her this way I hope that he
delivers on diving into the psyche just
as much as the cool elements we want to
see that's a big part of what split and
break will do is explore the lifestyle
above the hero and the villain and I
like what they're hinting out with
Samuel Jackson about letting this be
exposed to the world that these powers
do exist so I feel like it's gonna have
some crazy-ass ending when it all comes
to fruition it looks like Bruce Willis
gives a [ __ ] again which I'm really
happy about I feel like I might be one
of the few dudes who he'll show up for
bring back the kid from the sixth sense
yeah he's got a superpower to see
showing up at the end let me bring in
Will Smith Jaden with there no fear
thing and then you bring in you know
that last airbender huh oh no that was
too no no no Stuart little conjoining on
it who you like you know Rocket Raccoon
but smaller not part of that and we're
gonna subscribe you the real rejects
thanks guys click that notification bell
and check out javi and Achara on the get
Jabby youtube channel link in
description box do it right away and
check us out on patreon full-length TV
show reactions weekly Q&A is music video
coverage would love to have you become a
patron eject today